I'm very happy to introduce Cynthia
larch according to Wikipedia is an
American computer scientist and Gordon
Makai professor and Radcliffe Alumni
professor at Harvard she has done a lot
of foundational work and distributed
computing and cryptography and a bit as
well
today she's going to tell us about the
relationship between group and
individual and oceans of algorithmic
grass thank you thank you
organizers who when you invited me to
speak I said well I'll probably want to
talk about fairness is that okay and
they said yes and I've been thinking
about some of these things for a long
time and I hadn't really forced myself
to try to pull the threads together so
this talk is the first attempt to do so
and it was it was gratifying
so anyway appreciate that okay so many
do have seen a slide that looks a lot
like this already I'm not going to
belabor the point we're talking about
algorithmic fairness we have a
population that's very diverse and the
concern somehow is that different groups
are treated differently in an
inappropriate way now sort of following
the the classical paradigm from
cryptography the approach that we tried
to follow when we started this work back
in the summer of 2010 was to first
define what we mean by fairness then
find algorithms that give us fairness
and ultimately then we were going to
look for composition theorems no so just
the kinds of stuff that you've been
seeing here too
so the definitions of fairness that are
in the literature basically fit into two
categories
the group notion promotions are
essentially statistical requirements
about the ways pairs of groups are
treated so the classical example it's
really easy to understand the
statistical parity if you're admitting
students to a university and you have a
well-defined notion of what your
population is then the fraction of
admitted students that belong to the
minority group should be the same as the
fraction of the minority and the
population as a whole that is a
statistical parenting and there are a
number of difficulties with statistical
parenting so even early on we rejected
it in general as a fairness notion so
then we looked at a different approach
which we call oh I shouldn't I should
mention sorry despite this almost all of
the very large literature on algorithmic
fairness deals with some form of group
fairness definition they do not deal
with a what I'm going to describe next
which is individual fairness individual
fairness intuitively says that for
looking at classification for example
for a given classification tasks to
people who are similar with respect to
that particular classification task
should be treated similarly by your
classifier and the difficulty with this
approach is that it requires a task
specific metric for determining for this
task how similar a pair of individuals
is so that was really problematic and
that sort of stopped for a while which
probably explains why all of the
literature and more or less is about the
group fairness notions but there's been
a really nice breakthrough or I think a
very intriguing grade through by Yale
Vento where she looks at building a
metric learning in
Trek from a human judge or an Oracle and
and it's an interesting mixture of sort
of learning theory and insights from
human-computer interaction and it seems
that there are certain types of
questions that humans find very
difficult for example how different are
these two people and there are others
that people find much easier so given a
B and C which of B and C is more similar
to a that's a simple query so she
manages to build a metric or some nice
approximation of a metric with very very
few difficult queries and on the order
of n log n easy queries okay and then
there were there were other works that
looked at specific questions under
various conditions for in the individual
fairness model and I'm that were really
intriguing but I'm not going to get into
them today you know while I said that
the group notions fail Andres under
under your scrutiny there is at least
some opinion in some legal scholars that
certain of these notions are appropriate
in certain contexts but the individual
fairness has a very strong legal
foundation that is the idea that would
said similarly situated people should be
treated similarly is absolutely
pervasive in law but of course that
still makes the question of or not it
poses the question of who is similarly
situated to whom and just to give you a
flavor of some of the issues that will
come up there's this question of if you
have if you're trying to build a metric
what should the metric capture so sort
of taking standard cryptographic
practice I'm going to assume that I have
a person X and X has internal randomness
and X interacts with an environment for
example the workplace environment
and there's randomness in the workplace
environment and then we have a will to
find it difficult to measure probability
pi X which would be the probability over
the randomness in X and in the
environment that X will succeed at say
the nice news company so this is a
company where people are treated well
and everybody can sort of reach his or
her own potential and success maybe it's
defined as staying at the company for at
least three years and having at least
one promotion during that time so
intuitively what we would want then is
that if PI X and PI Y are our stars are
close then x and y should be treated
similarly should have a similar chance
of getting hired but we could be at a
different company which is say hostile
to women so the nasty news company and
now well the chance that the woman will
succeed meaning that she'll stay there
for at least three years and have at
least one promotion
even if she's equally talented and
qualified for the job may be decreased
because the environment is hostile to
women so what should the metric be
capturing they you know the story at
nice news or the story at nasty news or
a lot now I also got you all to accept
really easily this notion of probability
I said okay well we've got randomness in
the person and randomness but when I
talk to people outside our filter bubble
of big crypto community they say what
what are you talking about you know this
isn't a probability but anyway before I
get into that we could say that PI X
somehow has men measuring the strength
of X's qualifications or maybe the
degree of ability well in actually
trying to assess ability we might factor
in stereotype
so what is stereotype threat stereotype
threat is a tendency to underperform in
conformance with a stereotype that
expects one's group to underperform so
before you all jump off to SATs one of
my favorite examples of this is an
experiment involving golf and I can't
remember whether it was a miniature golf
course or a real golf course but but
there's a stereotype that white men are
not good at sports and black men are
good at sports and if you tell white men
who are now going to you know swing this
Golf Club and you know hit the golf ball
that they're being tested on their
sports ability they do decidedly worse
than if you tell them I don't know
something that's very very neutral
whereas if you tell black men that they
are being tested on their sports ability
it has absolutely no impact
so the stereotype threat is affecting
the white men in that scenario and
stereotype threat has been measured in
lots and lots of settings so when you're
comparing somebody's qualifications now
let's go back to the SAT scores or the
math test scores or whatever it's
interesting to fact you know maybe you
should factor in stereotype threat okay
so anyway all of these are sort of
involved in what should the metric
capture
so as we indicated this question of the
individual probability is is very
elusive so just to focus on a couple of
scenarios what's the probability that a
person P will repay alone so when you
think about that how do you possibly
measure it and this is not a repeatable
experiment you're not going to give them
the loan and see what happens give them
a little see what happens and so on
there's no rewinding like there are and
you know proofs of zero knowledge so
what do you do well most people would
start to say well we think about people
who are similar to pay well what's the
right notion of being similar to pay
we're sort of back where we started from
and you also see perhaps that the
features that you use to determine who
might be similar to paying will become a
vector for introducing bias so you have
to be very very careful other kinds of
scenarios you you know there's a tumor
what's the probability that this tumor
with will metastasize under a certain
course of treatment or a really well
studied problem in the statistics
literature is forecasting so you have a
forecaster who now this is a sequential
version of the problem every day is
predicting what's the probability that
it will rain tomorrow what does that
mean the probability light will radar we
can't rerun tomorrow so what's this
collection that we're looking at to get
our probability and most poignantly of
course are questions like when you're
using predictive instruments to
determine whether somebody will go to
jail or not and you're asking what is
the probability that this particular
felon is going to recidivate its going
to commit another crime in the next you
know two years or violent crime in the
next two years so these are old
questions this is a paper published in
2018 by Philip David who had clearly
been thinking about these things since
the
early 80s and just look a little bit of
what the abstract says we survey a
variety of possible expectations of the
term individual risk he was in fact I
think motivated to go back all over all
of these things because of the use of
recidivism prediction instruments in the
court these in turn are based on a
variety of interpretations of
probability including classical and
numerator of frequency formal
metaphysical personal propensity chance
and logical conceptions of probability
and you know later it says although in
the end the comes the concept remains
subtle and illusive some pragmatic
suggestions for progress are made so
this is an old question even in the
statistics literature among people who
really really look at these things and
and by the way I should mention that
what I keep in mind when I'm thinking
about all of this is what if I were an
expert witness in court asked to explain
the meaning of a recidivism risk score
what would I say and why would I be
satisfied with what I've said I think as
a community the people who look at
algorithmic fairness have to have a good
answer to these questions okay so I just
want to mention that the probability
question is sort of germane even without
regard to fairness as we've seen in
forecasting for example and another way
to thinking about this is may be to say
that in some sense accuracy because
that's what we're trying to get at with
individual risk or individual
probabilities we can think of accuracy
as a first step in ensuring fairness
it's like first we try to figure out
what the situation is and then we want
to figure out how to deal with it and
make it fair okay so I said this was old
in the statistics literature here a
couple other places it comes up this
Ernest Burgess in who wrote
predictability is feasible he created a
parole prediction instrument comprising
a twenty one factor test to determine
based on group recidivism rates the
likelihood of success or failure of any
inmate eligible for parole that was
nineteen twenty eight and in fact the
the p knowledge astrium to this and they
built all of these categories and you
know you start to think that everything
is is it's going to be clear and and
objective and so on but they degenerate
into category names like narrow do well
and drunkard and so okay and one way of
thinking about these things is in the
words of bernard Harcourt whom we'll see
again in a moment the use of and he's
deliberately twisting language from the
insurance industry the use of
statistical rather than clinical methods
on large data sets to determine
different levels of criminal offending
associated with when one or more group
traits in order one to predict past
present or future criminal behavior and
two to administer a criminal justice
outcome some of my favorite writing on
this topic is in an article by barbara
Underwood who's just the current
Solicitor General of the state of New
York
so in nineteen seventy nine so long
before the big AI revolution first of
all in terms in talking about should I
went over this too fast clinical versus
actuarial judgments so actuarial
judgments are basically these predictive
instruments or literally actuarial
tables or the kind of thing that Burgess
was building clinical judgments
literally think about the psychologist
examining the prisoner and trying to
make a pretty
recidivism risk based on this detailed
one-on-one interaction so the clinician
you know brings to the table lots of
experience with other patients and so on
but it's not in this scenario using
statistical tables okay so Underwood
phrases it really beautifully she says
the distinction between clinical and
actuarial describes two different ways
of approaching the task of moving from
evidence to facts and that task presents
similar problems whether the facts to be
found are past or future so we've been
thinking about this as prediction which
is future but in a courtroom can we
actually start seeing these things
applying to the past let's figure out
what probably happened and there's a
little bit of this in the preponderance
of the evidence the majority of the
evidence anything so okay I just I
thought that was a beautiful way of
framing it now I mentioned a
psychologist for the clinical judgments
the psychologist certainly had been
thinking about this and in 1954 Paul
Mele published his book clinical versus
statistical prediction he comes down
pretty heavily on in favor of
statistical prediction and he says
essentially you know we think that
experienced people make really good
judgments they don't and he has a bunch
of studies in which he he shows this but
of course we have to see like which
which statistical stories was he
including is there selection bias in his
comparison set I don't know the
literature well enough to answer that
question I've seen some of the lawyers
write about this I should mention that
for everything that I'm telling you
about I did read the papers except I
couldn't read meals book it was just
filled with
references to schools of psychological
thought and and belief systems that were
completely foreign to me and does Martha
Minow put it it was like being
parachuted down into the middle of an
argument it's just a no idea what's
going on okay so Barbara Underwood wrote
that maybe this distinction well if
something's been argued that the
dichotomy between methods of prediction
is false because clinical methods are
simply inchoate and inarticulate forms
of statistical decision-making
so in other words the clinician is
generalizing from past experiences
that's a set of experiences and it's
another brain but then she points out
that the argument misses a critical
distinction a clinical decision maker is
not committed in advance of decision to
the factors that will be considered and
the rule for combining them I think
that's a really important point that our
literature needs to explore further I
want to go into that further so in other
words the clinician is adaptive now
remember she was writing in 1979 she did
not anticipate deep learning and so she
was somewhat attracted to actuarial
methods because you're giving your
method and you the method can then be
examined to see is it using race or is
it using gender and so on in an
inappropriate way as I say this did not
anticipate things that would be created
by deep learning where you simply have
no understanding of what what the
future's are and of course we also know
that it's a whole lot more subtle than
people realized anyway even when it
looks simple but I think that just yeah
no Frank shower Frederic shower takes
the position that as we said earlier all
clinical judgments are generalizations
and his view is you're going to
stereotype it's okay
get over it profile use profiling but be
careful and be ethical and he has some
really fun examples in his book about
about how this kind of reasoning is
viewed in court and and and and how it
doesn't yet work so so he gives the
example of the so called Blue Bus
company where very roughly speaking
there's an accident somebody a car was
hit by a bus and say 80% of the buses in
town are owned by the blue bus company
and 20% by the green bus company so
obviously the preponderance of the
evidence is it was probably a blue bus
you know is that is that reasonable way
of deciding the outcome or another
example and you've sold a large number
I'm sorry you have a stadium it's packed
but it turns out that when you look at
the ticket receipts you only have the
ticket receipts for just less than half
the capacity of the stadium so now for
any given person the probability that a
randomly chosen person was Gatecrasher
is more than a half preponderance of the
evidence
so can you sort of charge them all with
gate-crashing okay so anyway shower
shower is sort of in favor of permitting
profiling and stereotyping harcourt is
against it and he has a book against
prediction and he makes some really
interesting points which you know from a
computer science perspective makes sense
so he says hey the criminal population
is is not working on static rules when
they see how you are profiling the way
in which criminal behavior is
distributed is going to change and he
yes in the introduction to his book as
an example if it's known that the police
are profiling black drivers then the
black drivers may in fact stop carrying
drugs but the white drivers will up
there they're drug carrying because you
know they know they're not going to be
examined so and then he points out other
evils of life but I don't want to go to
it though okay great so that's hardcore
now interestingly he proposes
randomization as a solution so he says
for example that in the policing room
you should say randomly sample IRS
filings for audits or use some sort of
random sampling on the license plate
numbers for consensual searches in
sentencing he's very against using
predictive devices okay great we're
almost done with the background sonya
star points out that in a Stanford Law
Review article points out that basing
criminal sentences on actuarial
recidivism risk prediction instruments
that include demographic and
socio-economic variables violates the
Equal Protection Clause and this bad
policy it's an explicit embrace of
otherwise condemned discrimination
sanitized by scientific language however
I don't think that this has been we just
checked my notes to make sure I got this
right
our argument has not been accepted by a
court and it depends on impact analysis
which the current Supreme Court does not
like
now closer to home there was there's a
really really interesting nver article
by Kleinberg at all where they're trying
to look at the behavior of judges versus
algorithms and what they find is that an
algorithm is more effective than than
judges and so here a policy simulation
shows crime can be reduced by up to 20
4.8% with no change in the jailing rates
or you could flip it around and jail
populations can be reduced with no
increase in crime rates if you were to
use the algorithm the set of the judges
then you have to wonder how do you deal
with counterfactuals when the elected
and they do really beautiful things to
address that so I highly recommend the
paper just for the joy of seeing some of
these techniques ok so basically they
support meal they're saying that you
know we may think that the judges are
wise but they're not the algorithm is
wiser even yeah ok so let's get back to
individual probabilities we talked about
this a little bit so let's talk about
the tumor so here I'm sorry sorry I'm
sorry you didn't go through this list
yes I did
I'm sorry so here's the tumor
I've got this tumor and a study that
looks at certain aspects of the tumor
maybe certain parts in its DNA says that
forty forty percent of these will
metastasize by the way when I spoke to
radiologists about this she immediately
got distracted by the numbers that's a
huge number forget about that it's just
a made-up number
okay so you do a study it says the 40%
are going to metastasize maybe there is
a second study and the second study also
shows 40% and the second study is
measuring other features what did you
conclude should you conclude that in
fact it's gonna be 40% should you say oh
yeah yo you've got two sets of risk
factors this is terrible the chance is
gonna go way up you know who knows you
can't tell given just these estimates
what what is the right belief about this
particular tumor and I don't use belief
in a knowing way I'm not talking about
about Bayesian anything I'm just like
you just don't know what to make of it
okay and what if you have two different
studies that show different numbers what
should you think should your prediction
now go up if before you were gonna say
okay well everybody's saying 40 I'll say
point four I'll say point four so okay
so um this seems to be related to the or
at least something some days I think
this is related to a more classical
problem of combining the opinions of
experts and so you can think of an
expert as somebody who really shares all
of your values and beliefs and knows
something more than you do for example
the results of a study in which case if
you knew what the expert knew you would
change your book your belief to whatever
the expert believes because they think
the way you do and they just have more
information so here we've got two
different experts they know two
different things the results of two
different studies so perhaps you might
hope that the literature on combining
the opinions of experts can help I found
that very inconclusive but I don't rule
it out completely
now in the weather forecasting
literature there's they define the
notion of calibration maybe it was
defined before that but this is where I
first saw it so remember that this is
you know what's the chance that it's
going to rain tomorrow so your
forecaster imagine is just forecasting
day after day after day after day and is
producing some probabilities I listed
them here V double prime V V prime V V
double prime V V V followed by UW and so
on so calibration says if we look at all
of the predictions that say V all of the
days where they said V then on a V
fraction of those days it should have
ranked the fraction of days so in other
words on average the V predictions are
correct and the W predictions are
correct on average so for every value of
V you look at the days where V is
predicted then of the fraction of them
will have a ring I think usually these
things are defined in terms of infinite
sequences there are some finite sample
analogs in the literature okay and it's
often viewed as the cynic wanna know
forecasting if your forecaster the
literature is filled with comments along
the lines of if your forecaster doesn't
do this something's wrong with your
forecaster you might say well maybe my
forecaster consistently underestimates
well an infinite forecaster should
figure out that she's consistently under
estimating and adjust perhaps or okay
now going back to the tumor example the
statistics for these studies are based
on binary outcome data you know this the
the tumors did or did not metastasize
and so this gets us right away a
difference between simply having the
results for the studies and having the
data the outcomes on which the studies
were based because if you had the
outcomes and the intersection of you
know tumors that satisfied both of these
were were were there you would be able
to figure out statistics about the
intersection perhaps so so there is a
really important difference between just
having estimates and having the actual
data now if you're given the
expectations only you can choose values
for the different regions here so that
the expectations are preserved for your
two studies there's two sets s1 and s2
and in general if you have a whole
collection of sets a see you want to
then you have estimates for each set on
the probability of an event in that set
then you you can build well you can
build a predictor which is multi
accurate with respect to a collection of
sets meaning that the predictions that
you create will be on will on average
always match they ask the expectations
for the set so you'll always match the
expectations for the set of course I'm
wildly ignoring you know sampling error
and stuff like that and everything that
I say has to be adjusted to small small
noisy errors but forget that so so multi
accuracy I project saw I think it was
first proposed by Avery Johnson Kim Ryan
golden Roth Blum and it was a fairness
goal and it's kind of a warm-up for a
stronger goal that we'll get to in a bit
but this is interesting and you don't
need training data for you can just go
based on the estimates so notice that if
you have a pretty large a pretty large
collection of data points symbols
training data and the sets are large s1
s2 and so on are large and
your samples will give you good
estimates for the expectation for these
sets you've got enough samples from each
of the sets if you have enough data
points and the sets are not required to
be disjoint just like in this picture so
so while to get multi accuracy all you
need are the expectations if you have
training data then you can compute
approximations to these expectations and
you can get multi accuracy and I love
their algorithm and I really wish I had
time to show it but I don't know you can
have a multi accurate predictor or
scoring function but there are many
multi accurate scores to choose from
functions that you could choose from and
the expectation for the intersection is
not nailed down in general by multi
accuracy so getting back to this
recidivism prediction or tumor
prediction I don't know what I would do
if I see that this expectation is not
nailed down at all and the outcome also
may not be calibrated okay now if we
think about the loan example for a
minute and we try to think about
discrimination and lending and know
people are involved a little bit
different than when we just are talking
about tumors you want a large rich
collection of sets and Claude Steele in
his book whistling Vivaldi writes there
exists no group on earth that is not
negatively stereotyped in some way the
old the young northerners southerners
wasps computer whiz kids Californians
and so forth so this brings up the
question how do you choose which sets
you want to have in your group in your
collection of sets for your multi
accurate predictor or
what will be multi calibrated so you
know minimally you would like your
policies to be consistent with the
expected repayment rates for each group
and the expectations now are determined
by I don't know why the but sorry sorry
sorry so I skip that bullet just forget
it on to the next slide so the which
groups question which groups should you
include who decides so should the the
culturally dominant be the group that's
deciding which sets to include for multi
accuracy should we rely on the oppressed
to stick up for themselves here and say
hey you should treat us fairly you
should include us in this in this set
and in a groundbreaking 1994 paper Jost
and bono G argued that that members of
negatively stereotyped groups are
members of an oppressed group tend to
internalize the negative stereotypes and
and and don't even necessarily realize
that they thought to be asking for
better treatment or perhaps I should say
that we ought to be asking for better
treatment so there's evidence to show
that individuals generate beliefs about
themselves and stereotypes about social
groups in such a way that existing
situations are justified so they're
trying to we try to explain to ourselves
why this is okay rather than saying wait
this isn't okay objectively this is not
okay so what's the point of bringing
this up complexity theory rocks so the
approach taken in Avery Johnson at all
is to just say okay let's look at
something that will protect all groups
that are defined by small circuits now
the intuition here is that this will
probably capture or might capture we
hope all historically disadvantaged
groups
it does require though that the data
will be sufficiently rich to permit
identification of membership in this
group right so it has to be that based
on the data you can tell whether someone
is in the set or not otherwise it's not
hopeful okay so as I mentioned you can
actually achieve multi accuracy the
complexity can be hard it's related to
the create the complexity of creating
the multi accurate scoring function will
depend on the hardness of agnostically
learning this collection of sets but you
can build the function you know modulo
that you can have an efficient predictor
and the extra condition that they have
is multi calibration that scoring
function is calibrated on each set in
the collection simultaneously so you're
accurate in expectation not only overall
sets in the collection but within each
set if we look at the slice of people
that were assigned the value of e you're
accurate an expectation order those as
well so the first collection is fixed in
advance and sort of standard machine
learning techniques let you do this the
second one is determined adaptive link
and they use a differential privacy to
protect in the adaptive data analysis to
do this you know the collection of sets
is absolutely critical here and as I
said the hope is to capture sort of for
each task task specific semantically
significant differences among people but
the data that you have can be
differentially expressive so for example
think about AP classes in a wealthy
School District there are AP classes and
and college capable students have a
chance to prove this by taking AP scores
and in you know in the rated GPAs they
could even then get a weighted grade
point average that is above 4.0 because
you get an extra point for the a peak
but in an impoverished school district
you simply don't have that information
there aren't AP classes and there's no
way for these based on grades for these
colors these college capable students
I'm demonstrating this so what we have
here is that the data are differentially
expressive what you have is just not
enough and that's a really big issue we
think we have some way of at least a
one-sided test for this but they said
this is work in progress you know really
briefly and tell me when I have two
minutes left of so this led to a study I
mean we started studying ranking and the
question is why would we study ranking
so first of all you want to rank fairly
this is ranking is at the heart of
triage you've got an emergency situation
you have to make decisions and treat
people right okay ranking is often the
underlying impetus for the scoring
function right you want to score
everybody and take it people but so so
by studying ranking it actually helped
to inform us of what we want from a
scoring function also some affirmative
action strategies are a sort of merge
sort that is you partition the
population either let's say according to
high schools as is done in Texas and in
California or in Rome airs the roamers
theory about justice
you can stratify students by the
education level of the mother and then
you have a method of ranking students
within each of these strata and then you
take the top X percent from each group
and so this is what the UC system does
and the University of Texas System does
okay
and finally if you're an experienced
clinician and you're given ranking
information then you can sort of
translate that into a score by yourself
if someone tells you this is person is
in the top 10 percent of the risk
category you know something about how
likely they are and that actually brings
up a general there
which says that if you have fair ranking
and binary historical outcomes data you
can actually create a fair scoring
function but I don't have time I think
to talk about exactly what we do here
but we defined two in two hierarchies
the short hierarchies but there are two
hierarchies one of them is based on
thinking about treatment of pairs of
sets and what we want to avoid so we
have minimal requirements stronger
requirements and yet stronger
requirements and that's our first
hierarchy the second one is a notion of
evidence consistency so if you have a
ranking and you want that your ranking
will be consistent with the rank induced
by a scoring function that satisfy
certain properties so scoring scoring
functions immediately give you rankings
you just rank according to the score so
what are the properties that you would
want you look at increasing increasing
accuracy requirements in the scoring
function and we match up the levels in
the hierarchy and in fact the top levels
are equivalent and the top level can be
achieved by ranking to be consistent
with any multi calibrated scoring
function so here multi calibration came
in again in a different impetus and it
seems and wherein we can sort of whom
we're working on formalizing this but it
seems that any kind of stronger
requirements than the ones that we've
laid out will come will arise in the
choice of sets not in the not in the
treatment of the sets that you have
specified so an example is that ap
scoring you know not being visible in
the sets okay
last slide
perspective on on individual
probabilities so we're exploring a
possible analogy to indistinguishability
in the you know if positive and negative
examples are computationally
indistinguishable then our community
tends to think it's okay to assign a
probability according to the
distribution in some sense we we believe
this is the best we can do that
faced with computational
indistinguishability there's there's no
we're stuck so maybe we can think
analogously and we can say if the set c
is really rich so we've managed to get a
set that is not differentially
expressive maybe analogously it's
legitimate to treat any c multi
calibrated prediction function as if it
were the truth because in some sense
we're saying hey this is a really rich
class of things upsets these sets can't
manage to separate people so this is the
best we can do so that's what we're
exploring now and this is why this is
working prowess
[Applause]
thank you thank you this is very
inspiring talk I starting from the back
end with one question that you mentioned
I forgot the name of one of them
psychologists just when you said they're
learning inductively what's relevant
right that sort of what what they take
it this is a barber under one thought oh
wow it was wondering I mean in with the
mounting calibration you still a
constraint yes information you have and
and I guess one of the challenges what
gets into that collection right and is
there something in what you explored in
the multi calibration that would hint at
additional data that you might need or
where we're not like they might be
slightly distinguishable where you feel
like he is a lack of information you
know so I mentioned the problem of
differential expressiveness and and I
said we we have I think at least a
one-sided test for this so when it says
something is wrong here if something is
wrong
hopefully we can at least information
theoretically make that make it
two-sided so that that's that's the
direction we're pursuing for answering
that question
yes have you any comment on the issues
in redistricting in you know
gerrymandering versus fixing the
mechanism and looking at what comes out
that are currently before the courts
Aaron do you have a comment on fairness
gerrymandering Aaron has a paper
together with cons and well anyway no I
don't have there is a there is a
statisticians brief which which doesn't
help at the moment because it wallet has
makes an important point it totally
confuses the few issues that they've
been trying to grapple with but saying
that the judging the outcome judging the
outcome is not enough in giving you an
example that's I've only read a an
article based on it not brief itself my
exposure to that question is through a
couple of talks by mundo Cheng who has
done really interesting algorithmic work
but I I can't speak to the issue you're
asking about but so if you discover a
new category we want to add rich your
set sees is that possible sort of as a
after that means oh I'm sorry
you're asking if you can rebuild the
algorithm the actual method but it's
sort of wondering if if you had imagined
that you start learning about more cases
of just I start with I'm an alien I come
in
which categories are you have
experienced discrimination I learn
everyday about more and more and I build
my circuit that's it classy
overtime so so yes you can but I think
that the hope is that by saying well
we're gonna do this for all small
circuits that we won't need to know I
understand there's a big complexity
issue in doing something for all small
circuits and so the results are
existential in this case rather than
efficient but I don't see why you can't
redo it there's no reason why you
couldn't redo it yeah so in in the
actual construction of the algorithm in
some sense the first thing you know you
pick a set and you arrange probabilities
so that that set is happy and then you
you now look for another set that's
unhappy in a really typical way and then
there's a potential function argument
that says you don't have to do this very
often so it may well be the case that
for many new sets that you find it
wouldn't even affect the circuit the
circuit you have is just fine you don't
have to there's not a piece of the
circuit that's built for every set in
the collection you can get by with way
fewer
yes Roca I think I saw Adam stand up but
if I can my question back to the
individual probabilities for all
possible sets what with innocent
indistinguishable and then you feel
comfortable using the probability that
book was what you said the day and
that's the best we can do right then
yeah so I I think it's an overstatement
to say I feel comfortable but but we are
we are thinking about feeling
comfortable with this okay so how does
this how is this different then sort of
initially when you stand out and say I
have you know a set of covariance a
predicted probability you know that that
of course only works in the distribution
and an expectation but it still
individual one of the things that's
going on here and you're you're doing
this I don't know you're solving a set
of simultaneous equations right so you
don't just have one collection of
features and you're measuring people who
are like that on those features and
using their probabilities you're you're
gathering much richer information and
you're solving for pieces you you're
solving so that you get something that's
consistent with all of the evidence that
you've seen and the evidence can involve
groups that this person isn't even part
of that contribute to the set of
constraints
let's take further questions offline
[Applause]